As far as the non-Muslims are concerned,
if the non-Muslim knows what is awaiting
from them in Akara that they're going to
go to hell and a prophet said the least
fire, the least pain if it
reaches your soul, your brains would
boil. So if the non-Muslims know what is
awaiting for them in the next life even
if they the most poorest man in the
world they will think they in Jenna
correct because they know what's going
to happen there you're a little bit hot
you know we want air condition we want
this we cannot stay without it there the
least punishment if the fire touches
your soul your brains would boil imagine
So even the worst human being who's a
non-Muslim would consider this as
paradise. So this is the explanation of
the hadith of the prophet of Sai Muslim
volume number 7 had number
7417. The glorious
Quran the last and final revelation of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala. It has the
solutions for the problem of humanity.
If it is a revelation and last and final
and after that no other revelation will
come. One of the requirement is it
should have the solution for the
problems of humankind. And the glorious
Quran it is the solution for the
problems of humankind. It is the
furan it is the criteria to judge right
from wrong. The glorious Quran has the
solution for racism. Allah says in surah
chapter number 49 verse number 13.
Oh humankind, we have created you from a
single pair of male and female and have
divided you into nations and tribes so
that you shall recognize each other not
that you shall despise each other and
the most honored in the sight of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala is the person who
has tawa the criteria for judgment in
the sight of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala.
It's not color. It is not age. It's not
wealth. It's not sex. It's not race. It
is tawa. It's god consciousness. It's
piety. So Islam has the solution for
racism. Islam has the solution of
terrorism. One verse of the Quran is
sufficient to prove that
Islam is against terrorism and has the
solution for terrorism. Allah says in
surah maida chapter number 5 verse
number 32. If anyone kills a human being
unless it be for murder or for spreading
corruption in the land it is as though
he has killed the whole of humanity.
Allah says if any human being whether
Muslim or non-Muslim kills any other
human being whether Muslim or non-Muslim
unless it be for murder or for spreading
corruption it is as though he has killed
the whole of humanity. And the verse
continues, if anyone saves any other
human being, whether Muslim or
non-Muslim, it is as though he has saved
the whole of humanity. So this one verse
of the Quran is sufficient to solve the
problem of
terrorism.
Quran has the
solution for inequality, for injustice.
Allah says in surah 4 verse number
that oh you believe stand out for
justice as witness to Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala even if it be against yourself
against your relatives against your
mother or father against your parents
whether they be rich or poor Allah
protects all so when you are giving
witness to Allah subhananaa irrespective
whether the witness will go against
yourself against your parents against
your relatives the rich for the poor.
Allah protects all. Quran has the
solution for alcoholism and drug
addiction. Allah says in the Quran in
Surah Maida chapter number 5 verse
number
19, oh you believe most certainly
intoxicated and
gambling dedication of stones, divation
of arrows.
Please accept this
handwork. Abstain from this handwork
that you may prosper. So the solution
for alcoholism is it is prohibited. It's
haram.